What do you got there?
Oh, just choosing some classes for
college. This one looks interesting.
And this intensive.
Nope.
Drop that game day, buddy.
For the first time ever, Luke and I are
taking part in the sport of kings.
The savory science.
We're teamed in a parent child hot dog
eating contest.
We've been training for weeks, and I'm
proud to say that Luke, like his old
man, is blessed with a doggers mouth.
I felt something. Tear inside.
Push through it.
You'll thank me when you start to feel
the gorgeous high.
Ah! What the hell?
Oh, it was a hot dog making you angry.
An angry stomach is 12% larger.
I think we've got a real shot to take
down Rhonda and Sandy Hodiak.
But they're undefeated.
I guess that makes us underdogs, huh?
How long you been sitting on that one?
Not as long as you've been sitting on
that couch, huh?
Hey, can I get in on that floor bagel?
Luke, He's only getting a third of the
dog on his first bite. Anything less
than half. And you're playing for
second.
Well, the good news is, the fourth is
weeks away.
Um. It's-- It's today.
Today? June?
Yeah, go on. Oh.
There you are. It's almost time for our
show. What are you wearing?
Clothes. I to get back into school mode
before I lose my edge.
Mom, you might want to think about
rejoining life before your brain
freezes, too.
Yeah. Don't you worry about me.
Ha, ha.
What's that?
Oh, um, listen.
No. Dad wants to have this talk with
his son, but you're just not eating
enough hot dogs.
I'm sorry.
Some reason I just.
I can't focus.
I think what Luke is trying to say is
he's too old for this contest, and he
doesn't have the heart to tell you.
That's impossible. I'm an adult.
I'm still super into it.
Yeah. My 20s should be my prime hot dog
eating years.
That was just my first attempt.
I'm going to figure this out.
Hang on. Despite what Alex says, I have
not lost my edge.
Something just clicked.
Fine. You're right.
It's college.
It is?
I'm distracted because I'm feeling some
pressure on which classes to take.
But don't worry. I'm going to figure it
out.
Wow. How could you tell?
Just a.
Perceptive guy.
I wasn't talking about Luke.
The clicking was in my jaw.
My old TMJ injury was back thanks to
all the training. I got it in college
when I bet my roommate I could out
frisbee catch his golden retriever.
And guess who wo-- ouchh.
Hot dog eating contest is about to
begin. Sorry I'm not in worse shape for
this.
Don't worry about it, buddy. You've had
a lot on your mind.
Any luck choosing your courses?
Not yet.
I don't really want to talk about that
right now.
Maybe you're putting too much pressure.
More than just picking classes.
Okay. Can we just drop it and focus on
what we're doing here? Yeah, of course.
Exciting to be in the competition, huh?
Instead of sitting up in the bleachers
like the last three years, I guess.
Scary, sure.
But it does feel good putting our butts
on the line. You lose 100% of the hot
dog eating contests, you don't enter.
Dad, I know what your bumper sticker is.
I know what you're trying to do here,
but college is different.
I mean, you screw up at community
college, you're out of options.
You're not going to screw it up.
I've messed up a lot of things in my
life. I'm scared.
I'll do it again. Good.
What? Being scared means you care.
Maybe. Maybe that's what's been missing
in the past.
It's the biggest thing I've ever tried
to do. Contestants ready positions.
Just take it one step at a time.
Don't worry about the 50 to hopefully
75 hot dogs you're going to eat.
Just worry about the dog in front of
you and wet the buns.
Eat.